I see tree my all-time favorite moments
advert in 21 years of interviewing
celebrities when Dwayne Johnson sang to
me so I knew that I was gonna ask him to
do it again when we sat down to talk
about his new action movie rampage but
first I wanted to hear about his
rambunctious life at home with two
daughters and a baby girl on the way the
hardest for me what I'm realizing is
just being 10 steps ahead especially
when things go sideways and they start
to feel if a temperature goes high a
little bit or they start to get sick a
little bit just thinking ten steps ahead
because then your instincts kick in your
daddy instincts kick in
the new baby will between second with
Beyonce Lauren hacchyan the couple has
been together for more than 10 years
wedding plans anytime soon but I knew
you were gonna get me we was going to
get married in the spring and then we
got pregnant and Lauren felt like well
you know what I don't know if mama wants
to take pictures being pregnant and
wedding guests so we're just gonna wait
so first comes baby then comes marriage
they haven't yet settled on a name but
Dwayne revealed that Tia is one of two
names on their short list T I use there
was an option we didn't give me the
other one well they are Naomi I like it
[Laughter]
well Naomi with Annie and the rock face
off against mutating animals wreaking
havoc on the streets of Chicago and
their new action-adventure rampage
we know how difficult it is to be an
action hero but it's pretty difficult to
be a dad to three girls which is harder
oh by far this is cake I mean the idea
of being a daddy to three girls varying
ages by the way sixteen two and a half
and now a baby yeah but there's nothing
better and yep the Rock has that very
special secret weapon to calm his girls
this is a Hawaiian lullaby that I've
sung to Simone something to Jasmine I'm
gonna sink two baby teeth here we go
ahi Vale uh my name no co uk a kilo and
that is twinkle twinkle little star we
all just fell in love with him even more
didn't me
and did you really do this a baby to you
natural
[Music]